but so the biggest change today is just
going to be warm temperatures way above
normal but by next week we may be adding
a little snow to our mountains and
hopefully we can pick up a little rain
too so a lot going on in the eight day
forecast this morning temperatures
trying to cool off from yesterday's
mid-80s just about 10 degrees above
normal for our thursday afternoon we
still have some neighborhoods in the low
60s right there on the strip downtown 61
60 in green valley otherwise we're in
the 50s centennial hills you just went
back up to 62 50 degrees at red rock and
40s in the mountains so we're looking
for very light winds and more warmth
today high pressure really strengthening
that's going to drive temperatures way
above normal and will likely set a new
record high for today's date and into
tomorrow 90 degrees yesterday our first
80s of the year today we're just going
to leap right into our first 90s of the
year sunrise with 6 6 6 37 excuse me and
6 57 is the sunset still pretty quiet
across the west the northwest getting in
some clouds ahead of this
strong system that will affect us by the
beginning of next week for sure and rain
and snow working its way off the east
coast aren't really a lot of travel
problems across the country if you are
traveling just so warm across the
southwest likely death valley will see a
hundred degrees today and tomorrow and
then 90s across many desert locations
and across the southwest of phoenix
going to be extra hot too in the 90s
high clouds kind of coming into the
southwest coast and we could see a few
of those by tonight beautiful in the
mountains in the upper 60s red rock in
the mid 80s out at the lake some slight
southerly breezes and highs in the low
90s today take lots of water i mean
these numbers don't look too tough if
you've lived in the desert for a while
but
we just don't get this kind of heat in
march it's just too soon
90 degrees for the valley today
again that will be a new record 74 is
the norm and we'll be well above that
today and tomorrow so yes just downright
hot we will get some clouds coming in
through the weekend and then breezy to
gusty southwest winds sunday and then
monday those will be northerly winds
showers could start during the morning
commute on monday
likely through the afternoon early
evening and then slight chances left for
tuesday we need the valley rain there
will be some snow in the mountains we
need that as well and then we'll dry out
and warm back up to near 80 for the rest
of the week